haïti est dans la merde si tu m'avais
écouté au lieu d'aller petit clamart
systems vt jusqu'au cou dans le système
mois on voit j'étais libre
[Musique]
donc là on est sur mes routes poitevine
on est en pays mais l'uso on arrive sur
la commune de chasseneuil passé village
où j'ai grandi
ce qu'on a quand même une des plus
belles églises du poteau chance si bas
c'est là que le dernier moment pour la
pour l'enterrement de mon père quand
l'eau glacée la ferme et là c'est la
maison dans laquelle j'ai dormi j'avais
peint les volets rouges à l'époque plus
de 20 ans ils ont un peu passé tout ça
au moment de pâques tous ces saisonniers
le chevreau s'était plaint de chevaux
même dans le séchoir à tabac là dans le
bâtiment derrière il y avait jusqu'à
7000 chevreau en même temps les
chevreaux ils boivent du lait de la
poudre de lait et la poudre de lait à
l'époque on l'a payé 10 francs le kilo
donc sur une année enfin sur six mois on
sortait plus d'un million de francs et
d'aliments de poudre de lait imaginez
les frais vétérinaires et n'avait pour
deux ou trois cent mille francs c'est
donc ça va cumuler ça fait des charges
incroyable mais on était dépendant des
cours de marché quand on les vendait les
chevaux c'est à dire que mon père en
gros concrètement ils savaient combien
ça lui coûtait par contre il savait
jamais combien il vendait son chevreau
au moment de le vendre à l'abattoir en
fait est que dans l'agriculture qu'on
peut travailler à perte
c'est quand même assez dingue on
répercute pas le boulanger le bled lui
coup de temps il peut vendre sa baguette
le prix qu'il le décide il est menotté
la coopérative vous pousse à à
construire un bâtiment aidé par la
chambre d'agriculture le crédit agricole
s'appelle l'intégration coopératif vous
apporte les poussins ou les ports où les
veaux c'est la même chose vous apporte
l'aliment et à la fin ils vous
reprennent les animaux et vous disent tu
seras payé temps mais vous faites pas la
facture du produit c'est quand même fou
mon père est travaillée combien d'heures
travaillées tous les jours donc 12 14 16
heures par jour et tous les jours allez
un petit petite pause une petite pause
de dimanche à eux deux ils arrivaient à
peine à se dégager un smic et il ya des
mois où
j'ai rien et en 89 il ya eu un incendie
qui a tout ravagé ça c'est le premier
coup vraiment qui a été dur pour mes
parents puisque on n'étaient pas assurés
contre les pertes d'exploitation et on a
perdu 2000 chevreaux et donc 300 mille
francs à l'époque
en 89 c'est énorme pour une une petite
exploitation agricole et poutres noir
calcinés c'est des stigmates de
l'incendié même le gris du mur on avait
reconstruit rénové en fait ce bâtiment
pour pouvoir continuer la production
parce que c'est parce que vous brûlez
qui peut s'arrêter d'allergie à des
emprunts et à tous qu'il faut rembourser
donc pour ça que derrière on a continué
à grandir grandir grandir on pouvait
plus s'arrêter
on cherchait toujours des productions
différentes ou des manières de faire
différemment pour rembourser les crédits
qu'on avait tout simplement et c'est en
ça que mon père il a quand il est tombé
dans sa dépression il disait qu'il
s'était planté de boulot qui n'aurait
jamais dû faire ça qu'il lui aussi avec
le travail qu'il a fait il aurait mérité
d'avoir l'argent partir en vacances on
redoute est un vrai d'hôtel et les
parents les périodes estivales puisque
on recevait des cartes postales de la
famille qui était encore au camping de
là-bas en montagne c'est terrible de
recevoir ont porté deux jours trois
jours de temps en temps une fois je m'en
rappelle on est parti à arcachon on a
dormi dans la voiture parce qu'on ne
vais pas partir finalement il ya eu un
orage pas cause de l'orage n'a pas pu
faire les moissons et puis on est parti
à l'arraché puis on n'a pas trouvé de
tel et puis on a dormi dans la voiture
et en 97 8 ans jour pour jour après le
premier incendie
les nouveaux bâtiments flambeau site
chauffage encore une fois chauffage au
gaz
et c'est vraiment lors de ce centre cet
incendie en 97 que mon père a baissé les
bras
là comment c'est plus de deux ans de
d'une descente jusqu'aux en faire quoi
une dépression donc quand il n'a pas pu
se relever imaginer voir tout ça kravets
ses terres et moi j'étais dessous avec
lui on a essayé de sauver tout ce qu'on
pouvait en fait on sauve rien mais on
est on peut pas faire autrement que
d'essayer de sauver ce qu'il ya et là ça
a été une spirale une descente
l'abominable pendant plus de deux ans où
il s'enfermer dans sa chambre ou où il
voulait plus voir sa ferme mais il
voulait plus voir son métier et puis
jusqu'à un moment donné
ingéré des pesticides pour ce qu'il
cherchait une porte de sortie il ya un
agriculteur chaque jour qui se donne la
mort en france
là en 2019 donc mon père c'était il ya
vingt ans mais on peut dire que rien n'a
changé c'est même pire en fait
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui être agriculteur c'est c'est
aussi difficile qu'il ya 20 ans et
peut-être encore plus parce que un tiers
des agriculteurs vivent avec moins de
350 euros par mois il ya quand même un
truc qui marche pas les agriculteurs
sont ceux qui nous apportent ce qu'on a
dans notre assiette
il n'y a pas de pays sans paysans moi je
parle pas de bio parce que le bio ça
peut être des tomates acheminer du bout
du monde
élevé en serre faut raccourcir les
circuits pour tourner dans les fermes en
fait nous on voyait une personne ici on
était hyper isolé on a perdu le lien
avec le consommateur
moi quand j'étais gamin je rêvais
sûrement de reprendre et puis d'être
ingénieur agronome et pourquoi pas parce
que pour apporter cette agronomique
cette technicité pour continuer dans ce
modèle intensif et je pense être à la
tête d'une ferme de 250 300 400 hectares
moderne est un gentleman farmer
ouais je vais sûrement sûrement été dans
ce modèle là mais les événements ont
fait que non j'ai pas repris je reviens
quand même à la terre puisque regarder
on fait un film sur l'agriculture j'ai
fait des documentaires sur la culture la
terre j'ai des baskets mais elle est
amoureuse
on ne l'a toujours qui nous suit quand
je creuse toujours ce sillon de
l'agriculture et j'en sortirai jamais
puisque parce que c'est elle qui nourrit
et qui nous a qui nous a fait nous qui
nous a pris le pire est que nous amener
le meilleur